good morning everyone
and thank you for coming to our annual
new year's eve press conference
i am deputy chief kelly mcmahon with the
las vegas metropolitan police department
and i'm here briefing you on behalf of
lvmpd
because this year i had the honor of
being the incident commander in charge
of the strip
and downtown operations first and
foremost i want to
really give a huge thank you to switch
we are back here again this year
and i can't tell you how much the
partnership means to us
just as you look around this room what a
fantastic space to have
as our incident command operation
headquarters
um we really do appreciate it more than
you know the technology is fantastic
unlike anything that we've
had in the past i would be remiss if i
didn't start out by thanking all
the jurisdictions that make it possible
to have a
happy and healthy and safe new year's
eve here in las vegas
we don't do this by ourselves it is a
true collaboration
some of those partners are going to come
up and speak today but i really want to
thank all of the local
police law enforcement agencies that are
assisting us
as well as our fire partners and our
federal partners we couldn't do it
without you
so this year has been an interesting one
hasn't it um as it comes to a close i
think we can all agree on that
um things will look a little bit
different this year on the strip um
obviously there'll be no fireworks this
year which um which is you know what
most people come to see is that show at
midnight
um and i i believe that we're
anticipating a little bit of a smaller
footprint and far
in regards to the number of visitors
that we may have and even locals that go
down to the strip
but that being said lvmpd is taking this
as seriously as we have
every year our posture has not changed
we will have over 1200 police officers
on the strip another 200 that are
working downtown
as well as as i mentioned our partnering
law enforcement agencies and our federal
partners
as always we're going to focus heavily
on
the safety of everyone that comes down
to enjoy themselves
that being said we're going to be in
strict compliance with the ordinances
that are specific to new year's
no glass will be allowed on the strip if
you're seen with glass you'll be stopped
it'll be taken away and confiscated
it's very important especially in light
of what we just saw happen in nashville
again we're very focused on keeping
people safe so no large bags will be
allowed
on the strip nothing larger than 12 by
12 by 6
and i liken that to a paper grocery sack
any luggage any baby strollers any carts
that are being pushed around you will be
stopped
you will be warned and then after that
if you refuse to leave with that
property
we again will confiscate that property
this is all to make sure that people
stay safe
on this important night one of the other
changes this year is we are closing our
road closures we'll start at 7 30 pm
so please know that if you're in the
area or looking to get in or out of the
area 7 30 p.m we'll start a soft
lockdown on the strip
by 8 pm hard closure no there'll be no
vehicle access on the strip
this year the closer closures will go
from mandalay bay
to spring mountain the only difference
between this year and several years
in the past is that we will not be
closing down at sahara if anyone's been
to the strip lately
there's a lot of road work going on
there so we don't think we're going to
get as much foot traffic as we have in
the past
um so listen i've mentioned our
resources i've talked about those things
that we're going to be
taking a hard look at this year and so i
will also mention that we're very aware
of what happened in nashville while
there
seems to be one man that acted by
himself we never chance anything
so we are doing several protective
sweeps in the days leading up to
new year's as well as that night both on
the strip and downtown
we're being very vigilant at our
communication centers and other critical
infrastructure throughout the valley as
well
um and i will just close with this
because it is the year that we're in
um the governor still has a masked
mandate and a six foot
distancing mandate what we asked what i
ask on behalf of lvmpd
is that if you're coming to visit here
if you live here and you're coming to
the strip or downtown
please be mindful of these uh rules that
are in place
please wear your mask please try to
social distance we want you to have a
good time
we welcome you to have a good time but
we also don't want to send ourself back
months in this pandemic where um we have
more and more people going to the
hospital
and and we're closing down our city
thank you very much i appreciate your
time today
and now i'm going to turn it over to my
friend clark county commissioner michael
naft
leave it up to switch to have that thank
you very much
and to to that point thank you miss
fratwell and to switch for hosting us
once again this year
i'm glad to be back and appreciate uh
deputy chief mcmahon and her comments
along with
all of our partners here including clark
county fire department
and my friend councilman fiore with the
city of las vegas
uh well we all know and it has already
been mentioned that this year will look
it'll feel very different
uh we should all rest assured that the
las vegas metropolitan police department
and all of the stakeholders that are
here today
take this as seriously as they do every
year you heard a little bit
from metro but the planning will
continue to be as significant as it has
been in your past
and that goes along for clark county we
have uh
4 000 barricades that will be put up 26
street sweepers that'll be in place
excuse me so we're ready for anything
that comes our way
both from a maintenance side to protect
our strip and also from a law
enforcement side
it was also said that as in years past
bottles large bags strollers backpacks
will be prohibited
and that's a measure that was put in
place in clark county to keep all of us
safe
on events such as this occasion
but i can also tell you that this year
is very different
as a member of the board of directors of
umc the state's busiest hospital
i want to personally and uh
very directly ask the members of our
community to keep our medical personnel
in mind as you celebrate this year
um we're going to throw the biggest
party the world has ever seen next year
for this year we want to support our
economy we want to
make sure that everybody is able to
celebrate in their own way but it's
for this year do it with your close
group of friends and family keep that
group small wear your mask
wash your hands because we just uh we
are
nearing capacity in our community and we
do not
uh want to take any unnecessary risks so
i ask you
as much as anybody can i want to
personally make that request to our
community
uh please out of respect to the men and
women who are here today who are keeping
our community safe out of respect to the
doctors and the nurses and all those who
are staffing our hospitals throughout
our community
please keep them in mind as you make
your considerations
for just how you celebrate and also
consider
nowhere else can do it like the lvcba
this year
in theme with their only in vegas
they'll be kissing off
2020 so i hope you'll consider joining
them for that event confetti streamers
fireworks it's virtual
it's safe and it'll make sure that those
who live and work and play in our
community have an outlet
to enjoy this new year i'll be looking
forward to it
and that's at visit lasvegas.com so
again i want to thank all those partners
who will be working
on new year's eve to keep you and me
safe and i want to thank everybody in
our community who's really keeping them
in mind
and doing what's right for us to get
through this hurdle get through these
difficult times
so we can all celebrate together uh come
a year from now
thank you very much stay safe oh and
excuse me
uh now i get to bring up to the podium
my friend and colleague
our partner with clark county at the
city of las vegas
councilwoman michelle fiore
thank you all for joining us today while
this year's celebration looks a little
different
we are still committed to making sure
it's fun and a safe experience here in
the city of las vegas
all of our first responders will be out
in force
new year's from the men and the women of
our las vegas metropolitan police
department
and the nevada highway patrol to our
firefighters our city marshals
from the city of las vegas and the clark
county
keeping our residents and guests safe
it is our job to help them out we need
to ensure that we are
vigilant and acting as their eyes and
ears for our first responders so please
if you see something
say something make sure you get their
attention
we can also make the correct choices
that means
we have to wear masks it's still in the
governor's mandates
we have to keep our social distance and
calling for a ride if we're under the
influence
uber is extremely cheap there's no
reason not to call
if you are drinking we want everyone to
have an amazing night
but we also want to make sure that
safety remains our top priority
we are one of the safest cities in the
world
and that's thanks to our police forces
our first responders
and the private security at all of our
hotel and casinos
we ask our residents and our visitors
here enjoying our city to please make
sure
and keep our city safe as we ring in
the new year happy new years everybody
and now i'm going to have our clark
county
deputy fire chief mr warren whitney come
up
thank you where do i get one of those
gadgets
i need that from my house especially
when i
had coveted um
first of all i'm uh deputy fire chief
warren whitney from clark county fire
department
i want to reiterate
uh chief mcmahon's sentiment about
thanking switch for having us here and
providing
providing us a large enough space that
we can still take command of this
incident and also
remain socially distanced i would also
like to thank
the law enforcement metro nhp
the north las vegas police department
and all the supporting agencies private
ambulance companies
they have been uh great in the planning
of
our response for new year's eve
i'm not i can't really go into any
operational details
but what i can tell you is that we will
have a robust presence
on the strip more than adequate
for this new year's eve just as in the
past
years
we as chief mcmahon stated before
we are very aware of what's going on
around the world
uh specifically nashville and we are
fighting complacency we are keeping our
guys on their toes if you see
something say something rather be
overly cautious than regretful
and i'd also like to reiterate the
comments made
our hospitals are nearing critical
capacity
so while we want everyone to celebrate
the new year
we would like you to do it responsibly
and keep in mind social distancing
uh your masks i know that's hard and
everybody wants to get the year over
with
but there is light at the end of the
tunnel let's uh
try and stay safe and follow the
governor's mandates
and we'll get through this
that's it thank you i'd like to
introduce switch senior vice president
betsy fretwell
thank you chief thank you to all the
presenters
councilwoman and commissioner and deputy
chief
mahil once again
it's switch's honor to host this
incident command on a very important
evening
in our community and like the others
have said
while this one may feel a little
different switch is here
to help be a partner in this community
to keep it safe
and to make sure that everyone has a
safe and joyful ring in
of the new year here and we're really
proud to be a partner
with our law enforcement and public
safety agencies across the state
to make that a reality as you probably
all know
switch is a technology infrastructure
company located
right here in southern nevada and we are
really proud of that partnership
and we're happy to step in and create an
environment
where all of our public safety agencies
can be safe
and function effectively and keep all of
our tourists
and our residents safe on a very
important evening
i wish you all the very best for a happy
new year and
we'll be happy to answer any questions
that you have at this time
go ahead are there
now that you're expecting fewer people
on this trip uh this is for metro
um what are you are you expecting more
parties at home
and do you have any enforcement plans
for that
you know what thank you for bringing
that up um we do have enforcement plans
for that so this year we've uh
dedicated numerous and i again won't go
into
specific operations numerous resources
to go out disrupt
and prevent parties we've been as we
speak in the
this last week and leading into new
year's we're doing a lot of intelligence
work
um trying to figure out where some of
these larger parties might be planned
right the rental
properties that may not be renting
lawfully and legally
so yes we do have a plan for that we're
calling it our jumbo violent crime
initiative
so those folks will be specifically
focused and targeted on the rest of the
valley
um and i'm sorry i was remiss in adding
that earlier that our job is also to
keep the rest of this valley safe right
while ringing in the new year
downtown and on the strip so we've added
multiple resources to be able to do that
this year
so illegal fireworks will be handled in
the same manner that they always are
they'll be the
calls will go into dispatch it will
certainly not be a priority on this
night right the priority would be higher
level type calls but when we can get
there
we'll certainly get there and handle
those as well yes ma'am um
yes um so and of course most of you um
here locally are aware that over the
summer we saw
quite a jump in the violent parties that
were occurring at the airbnbs vrbos
so absolutely that team that we put in
place will be going out specifically
looking for those
we're already we've already begun to
target those those locations
and we're also putting out psas so that
folks know that if they do come here and
they're
renting um illegally and they host large
parties we're going to be knocking at
their door
i wish i could answer that i think that
we call it a guesstimate and our
guesstimate right now is maybe 200
000 as opposed to what we normally get
but again it's so difficult to say
that's why this year more than ever it's
important that we can we we
uh remain with the same posture in mind
as far as safety and that's why we're
dedicating the same numbers that we do
every year to these locations
no we don't have that concern at all i
think look here's the reality right
um people are going to come and knowing
that they're going to come here it's our
job to keep them as safe as possible
while keeping our own officers safe
and the best avenue to do that in
agreement with all of our strip property
leadership is to close the strip like we
normally do
what are our biggest concerns i think
that today i share with all of these
partners behind me that our biggest
concern
is that our hospital is almost a
capacity
we're going to manage whatever takes
place on the strip
and whatever takes place downtown but
the very real fact is
people are still getting sick at a very
high rate in this country and here in
our own home
and that worries me the most we really
have to work together to keep each other
healthy
any other questions gunfire
uh just some advice on that yeah so we
we do that every year as well we'll put
out psas but you know please folks
don't shoot a gun off to celebrate the
end of this year even though we all
can't wait to see it go
what goes up has to come down and that
would be a real tragedy so please
don't do that i know you're reminding
people to wear masks
so we don't we don't enforce that right
we don't actively enforce it and this
year
our bigger concerns will be the baggage
that's down on the strip um
it'll be the glass containers things
that we know historically have caused
the most damage and injury
however the best thing about working the
strip or downtown on new year's eve is
the level of engagement that our
officers have with the public
so anytime we're engaging i promise you
they're going to be asking them if
they're not to put their mask on
reminding them to stay safe and not not
just for the the party-goers right but
also for the health and welfare of our
officers
that have been working every single day
since this pandemic started along with
our fire partners that are going to be
out there with us
thank you folks i really appreciate your
time today